a frustrated uk manufacturing sector is
warning of production shutdowns
because of soaring gas prices energy
intensive industry such as steel glass
and ceramics have accused the british
government of doing nothing to help
they're contending with gas prices
around five times what they were six
months ago
during interviews on sunday the uk
business secretary would not commit to
supporting industry through the crisis a
cap on consumer bills has seen several
british energy firms go bust
in recent weeks
now this morning in the uk the trade
body for steel makers demanded the
government take quote swift decisive
action to avoid a crisis in the industry
markets analyst craig earlham joins me
from london uh good to see you craig how
serious is this problem for steel makers
in the uk
well it's clearly very serious and i
think the next few weeks are going to be
critical
one of a few things really needs to
happen either the price
of energy needs to come down organically
which would likely be triggered uh by
increased supply from russia which still
looks relatively unlikely at this stage
we need to see a significant increase in
the in the in in in gas coming from
somewhere else either from norway or uh
or from other sources be that higher
wind turbine to buy an output or
something
similar um or the government needs to
ultimately step in because the longer
they wait the worse the problem is going
to become we've seen in europe for
example that other countries have
already started to step in removing
charges and levies to try and ease the
pressure on businesses and the
alternative solution is obviously going
to be subsidies which again is going to
be something that the government will
have to undertake as they have for
example with fertilizer companies
already they're clearly very reluctant
to do so but this wouldn't be the first
time they've changed their mind so um i
don't think we can discount it all
together now you mentioned it their uh
reluctance within the government there
seems to be disagreement on whether to
help or not so is the government going
to step in here
i think they will ultimately they're
always going to say at this point that
they don't want to do it they're always
going to hang on as long as they
possibly can we've got plenty of
evidence of that in the past but we've
also got plenty of evidence of them
changing their mind uh when push comes
to shove they don't want these
industries to stop producing because all
you're doing is exacerbating a problem
for another industry if the steel makers
stop producing them what are the
construction industries are going to
suffer we're going to see price surges
here because of lower output and we're
effectively just passing the pressure
further down the line so i don't think
they're going to really avoid it at all
cost i think they're going to hope that
they get a bit of luck over the next
week or so and then i think ultimately
they're going to buckle because i still
struggle to see anything significant
happening that's going to bring down the
cost of energy and alleviate the
pressure naturally looking at the state
of the global energy market what could
relief look like
well ultimately relief is going to come
from one of a few forms it's going to
come from higher output from russia and
we know what the cost of that's going to
be that's going to be uh approval of the
nordstrom 2
pipeline it's going to come from a very
warm winter
in terms of the more medium-term picture
which again it seems like crossing your
fingers and burying your head in the
sand and hoping something else solves
your problem for you
um or it's going to come from subsidies
and i think governments are going to
unfortunately for them have to be very
active and the reason why they're
looking to do so is because the last 18
months has been so costly and as you see
here in the uk the price of that is
going to be higher taxes and there's
something that this government is going
to be extremely reluctant to do but is
clearly going to undertake and the last
thing they want to do is now start
subsidizing more and more industries and
increasing the amount of taxes they're
going to have to ask for and that's
clearly where the reluctance comes from
oh and markets analyst craig ireland
thank you
thank you
you